الباحث اهلا فشلت درست اشخاصا رفضوا حديثا
بعلاقه رفضوا حديثا بعلاقه حب ووجدت عده
اشياء تحدث في ادمغه الجميع
حب
الرومان بخو نشطه اذ يمكن ان تتوقف عن حب
شخص لانه هجره بل على العكس يمكن ان تحبه
اكثر كذلك المنطقه المرتبطه بمشاعر التعلق
العميق تنشط ايضا فما زال شعور التعلق
بالشخص لديك مستمرا النشاط يمتد المنطقه
المرتبطه بالالم الجسدي في الدماغ عندما
يتم رفضك في علاقه حب كما ان هناك ثلاث
مناطق دميه تنشط وترتبط بالرغبه والادمان
كادمان الطعام مثلا وللتخلص من هذه
المعاناه والتخفيف بالمشاعر الاسى وجدت
الباحثه ان الامر يتعلق بفتره ما بعد
الرفض فمع مرور الوقت نرى النشاطا اقل في
مناطق الدماغ المرتبطه بالتعلق اي ان
الوقت كفيل بالنسيان سالنا الناس في
الاردن كيف تتجاوز علاقه عاطفيه فاشله
نتابع الاجابات
[موسيقى]
هلا ممكن يعني
بتتجاوزيها بالشغل يعني
تلهي حالك بالشغل اكثر وممكن الواحد يتعلم
من غلطه وفي مثل بحكي لك الشاطر بتعلم من
الغلط اول اشي بدي احاول اركز على حالي
اتعلم من هاي عشان المستقبل
اركز على عيلتي على انجازاتي على شغلي
احاول احسن من حالي واتعلم عشان
العلاقات الجاي تكون اخدت خبره بهذا
الموضوع بتعرف على ناس جديده بكون
علاقات اجتماعيه كتيره يعني فبحس هذا
الشيء ممكن شوي شوي يطلعني يعني دايما
بحكي لك اكبر نجاح للانسان نفسه نجاح نفسه
فانا اذا نجحت بنفسي فاكيد بدي اتخطى اي
اشي يعني ممكن ياثر علي بعدين كل حاجه انا
تخليت عنها عشانه هالغيها
خلاص يعني فما في تنازل فيها بصراحه وخلص
وبرميها من ورا ظهري ما برجع ان انا ابكي
عليها ولا اي حاجه خلاص دي علاقه يعتبر
فاشله خلاص وما بكررها ثاني
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات